Lot of people are faced
with this problem of
how do you evaluate the level of
security that comes with the system.
No one more concerned about this then,
for example, the Defense Department.
They have a lot of sensitive data.
So they actually address this problem
of how do you do security evaluation?
How do you establish how trustworthy or
level of assurance, level of trust that
you can associate with a given system?
And they actually came up with a trusted
computer system evaluation criteria.
This is work that goes
back to actually the 80s.
And this is called the Orange Book or
TCSEC Requirements.
Trusted Computer System
Evaluation Criteria.
What you see here is,
actually it doesn't the color.
Actually it is orange.
Copy the color page of that report.
Now one of the people who were involved
in designing that, Roger Shell,
who signed it, my copy.
So I just provided you
a picture of that.
So the question is if you
are sort of tasked with this,
develop a sort of violation
criteria that we can use to
assess the trustworthiness or
security of the system.
What would be those criteria?
I think some of the discussions we have
had for example about functionality and
how well it's done and so
on, should actually factor into these
requirements that we're going to have.
So the Orange Book that I mentioned sort
of captured the evaluation criteria,
and came up with sort of way to
place a system in a division,
and within a division, a certain class.
So, the four divisions were D,
C, B and A.
The less than really refers
to the least trustworthy and
we'll see why D was
the least trustworthy.
And A was the highest level of trust.
And within that, for example,
the division C had C1 and C2, so C1
doesn't do certain things that C2 does
for it to be more trustworthy, okay?
So this ordering that we have
is going from least trustworthy
to the highest level of trust.
B1, B2, B3 means three classes
within the duration B.
Well, D really didn't
have to do anything.
If you didn't do, think about
your old MS Dos, if you didn't
isolate the trusted computing base
from untrusted code, basically
untrusted code could hook operating
system functions in whatever way.
There's no protection against tampering,
bypassing, or things like that.
See, one of the things it has to do is
do authentication and access control.
Okay?.
Access control.
It only has to do discretionary
access control but
of course to do access control it
also has to do authentication and
if it does that then it addresses
a bunch of other things.
Just sort of giving you
quick highlights here but
of course in a TC isolation and
stuff like that has to be here too.
So that places you in division C.
If you implemented
mandatory access control.
For example, BLP like model, where
that will move you up to division B.
And you can verify,
use formal verification techniques.
Specification in verification.
If you went that far,
then that's what will be needed for
you to get into division A.
Most systems that we use that
the security features that they provide,
commercial systems that are widely
deployed, they're basically in
the C division and C1, C2, or
whether they move up to get B1,
of course,
they have to do mandatory axis control.
So we said SELinux, for example,
does implement Mac So C1 and
C2 actually depends on
what functionality.
So here it, shouldn't be confused by
the fact that this we're talking about
functionality with discretionary and
mandatory access control.
This is actually how well effort you put
into making sure there are no problems.
So it's how well you you do,
you testing, testing,
based on all these auditing support and
audit logs and things like that.
You will have different classes, but the
main idea here is that most systems that
we use widely these days,
they basically division C some
implement Mac features and they get
into this division B1 that I have.
If you want to move up to B2 for
example, what you may have to do is,
you have to, whatever security
model that your system is,
underlies your system, you have to have
a proof of correctness for that model.
Or you also have to have a speck for
the TCB.
It doesn't have to formally done,
but you have to have a narrative
specification of the TCB and
what it does.
Of course if you want
to move up to B3 or
A1 beside that's formal verification
that you have to do an,
that the TCB is implemented
correctly and things like that.